What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And welcome to another episode of
Challenge Pongfinity
This is the series where YOU
Challenge US
With your craziest ideas related to table
tennis.
If your comment gets picked
We will feature it in our next video
And give you a shout out.
So make sure you leave your comments and ideas
In the comment-section below!
Otto-Pekka Ojala wants us to play with rocks.
This is my weapon
And Miikka and Emil can challenge me with
these.
This shouldn't be so hard.
This one is from Leo Solheimslid Johansen
He wants us to see us do 60 shots each
In under 1 minute.
I'm sure we will do it under 50 seconds.
So that was 120 shots.
Now it's time to play with this chain saw.
Let's go!
Thanks for watching guys
Hope you enjoyed it!
If you have an even crazier item we should
play with
In the next video
Leave a comment in the comment-section.
Remember to subscribe
And watch our previous episodes here.
Until next time!